Oh, ich muss das Herz halt entknoten.
So, entknoten das Headset am Start.
Und wie läuft's?
Warum lernst du?
Willst du immer spezielles machen?
Interessiert es dich einfach?
Oder musst du?
Muss du?
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen?
Du musst.
Das ist problematisch.
Berufsschule, äh ja gut, Berufsschule.
Für die Berufsschule musst du nix großartig lernen.
Berufsschule macht man auf einer Arschbacke.
Da kommt du über drei Hello World Print-Zeilen nicht raus in den drei Jahren.
So und was gibt's Neues Leute?
Du kannst jetzt einen Raspberry Pi 4 für 180 Euro kaufen.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, also richtig unsinnig.
Also wer aktuell keinen Raspberry Pi hat, dem kann ich echt nicht empfehlen, sich einen
Raspberry Pi zu holen.
Ich meine 180 Euro für einen Raspberry Pi, die sind wirklich, die sind wirklich nicht
mehr ganz bei Sinn.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Okay, den 4er gibt's für 123 Euro und das ist tatsächlich noch relativ günstig.
Normalerweise kostet die 4GB Variante glaube ich 45 Dollar oder sogar nur 35 Dollar.
Zero 2W habe ich tatsächlich welche hier, weiß ich nicht, was die aktuell kosten.
Ah okay, kostet das doppelte, kostet das doppelte von, ist nicht verfügbar.
Ja Zero 2W habe ich hier zwei Stück hier liegen, habe ich mir direkt zur Release gekauft, als
es die gab.
Weil ich mir dachte, das kannst du bestimmt nochmal gebrauchen.
Ich glaube ich mache jetzt doch mal ein paar Tabs zu, es wird mir ein bisschen viel.
Ja ja, ich habe mein eigenes Video an, Cringe, ich weiß auch nicht warum.
So, erkennt man jetzt schon ein bisschen was, nee okay, aber hier mal zu.
Machen wir mal das.
So, mal den ganzen Crap hier schließen, ich brauche aber eh nicht mehr alles zu machen
hier.
Bäm.
So, jetzt erkennt man jetzt ein bisschen was oben wieder.
Ja, habe ich, ist nicht meins, habe ich auch schon im Vorfeld gesagt, so Reality Sachen,
das ist, das kannst du prinzipiell ja eigentlich gescheit nur im Team spielen, das wäre noch
nicht so wild, aber es ist halt, sagen wir mal so äußerst langsam und gestellse alles,
das ist nichts für mich.
Ich mag das, dass ich erkenne wo die Gegner sind, die mich beschießen.
Dankeschön für den Sub, ich mache mal schnell ein paar Updates, wobei ich kann nicht, mein
Terminal ist blockiert.
So, kurz eine Runde Updates, ich glaube das haben wir gestern schon gemacht, aber ich glaube
wir haben gestern versucht vergessen zu restarten, kann das sein, irgendwie fühlt sich die VM
ein wenig laggy an und ich weiß nicht genau warum, Firefox laggt rum ein bisschen, es
ist der Twitch Chat, der rum laggt, äh ich reboote mal, schade ja nichts, moin hast du
für deinen Cuddy Server die DNS Challenge für Let's Encrypt, da kann es doch keiner
was darunter vorstellen, dass ich das noch nicht gehört habe, höchstwahrscheinlich
verwendest du das mit Let's Encrypt oder hast du was eigenes, ja weißt du wie man das ganze
testet, ja mit Let's Encrypt kannst du die Staging Server nehmen von denen, Let's Encrypt
hat Staging Server, damit ist das deutlich großzügiger was du für Zertifikate machen
darfst am Tag, guck 30.000 pro Woche das sollte ausreichen zum testen würde ich sagen, weil
ich glaube ansonsten sind es 300 oder so pro Woche bei den echten Let's Encrypt Dingern,
du du du, ja teste es mit den Staging Servern, teste es mit den Let's Encrypt Staging Servern
und dann, wenn alles funktioniert, dann stell um auf die Live Server und du kannst ja auch
ein paar mal testen, dann blocken die dich nicht, die blocken ja generell keinen, die
haben halt Rate Limits und du wirst ja nicht wirklich geblockt, du kriegst halt für ja
quasi 8 Tage kein Zertifikat, das ist dann halt das blöde da dran, oh, du du du du,
Restore, so ich hoffe den Twitch Chat brauche ich hier eigentlich nicht, wobei, warum eigentlich,
lass mal den Twitch Chat hier auch mal auf, so, ich kann den Twitch Chat hier nicht aufmachen,
ich hab hier nicht mal FFZ, Moment, ich hab Better Twitch TV, ok, soll mir auch recht
sein, hab ich Better Twitch TV, nice, weiß nicht so genau warum, aber anscheinend ich
hab Better Twitch TV drauf, gut, es ist wahrscheinlich so essential schon, ich hab wahrscheinlich
schon in der Default Installation, in meinem OS Image ist wahrscheinlich schon FFZ drinne,
so, machen wir den Krempel von gestern mal auf, zack, ich hab mich jetzt auch angemeldet,
mein Go Land ist jetzt, guck, ich kanns euch zeigen, hab mich vorhin mal eingeloggt, mein
Go Land ist jetzt registriert bis 19. Juli, was, Subscription expired, ich hab mich eben
eingeloggt, ich hab mich eben eingeloggt mit im Jetbrains Toolbox, also backt das noch
rum oder was, keine Ahnung, kein Schimmer, nice, so muss das sein, ich hoff du hast im
Vorstellungsgespräch auch gesagt, du hast Wupplo aus Prime subscribt, das gibt extra
Punkte, muss ja nicht stimmen, ja, aber, dann sagen die, jaja, klar, Pfeifert, den wollen
wir haben, doch, doch, das, achso, Moment, jaja, gut, wenn du es testest, erneuerst du
ja nicht, richtig erneuern kannst ja bloß alle 30 Tage, dann musst du, musst du, ne,
das stimmt, aber wenn du es testest, dann schmeißt du die Zertifikate ja weg und lässt
sie dir für die gleiche Domain neu ausstellen, immer wieder, bis es geht, also ich hab WSL,
sowohl auf der Arbeit als auch hier, aber ich benutze WSL eigentlich nicht, ich benutze
so meine Linux VM, WSL, WSL ist so das so halbherziges Zeug, weiß nicht, WSL ist so besser als nichts,
aber auch nicht so das ganze, so, weiß nicht, mir ist ein vollständiges Linux in der VM
tatsächlich immer noch lieber, Alter, ich hab Anfälle gekriegt mit Rust, ich hab mir
das jetzt ja Offstream nochmal angeguckt und ich hab versucht Webrequest zu machen, Alter,
wie kompliziert kann man es machen, einfach Webrequest, ich, okay, ich war dumm, ich wollte
Async, Webrequest machen, die Synchronen gehen ja noch halbwegs, aber ganz im Ernst, Alter,
was das, was das ist, guckt euch das mal an, eQuests oder so, komisch heißt dieses Package,
Await, ganz, ganz abartig, ja genau das meine ich, guckt euch das mal an, ganz im Ernst,
die haben sie nicht mehr alle, ja, das sieht erstmal easy aus, ja, bis du dann feststellst,
das Beispiel funktioniert so ohne weiteres gar nicht, weil du Tokyo nicht installiert
hast und Async darf nicht Main sein, stellt man dann fest und dann stellt man fest, was
zum Teufel ist Box, dünn, Standard, Error, Error und dann wird man feststellen, ach fuck,
es geht ja nur, wenn das Fragezeichen hinten am Await dran ist, dass er das anpackt in
den Error, das heißt, wenn du was anderes als Return Word irgendwo hast außer Box, dünn,
Standard, Error, Error, dann funktioniert es nicht, also ganz ehrlich, das ist wirklich,
das ist echt Way to Dank, ja, warum haben wir das eigentlich mal als E-Mode, ich hatte
das doch mal als E-Mode, jetzt haben wir es wieder, jetzt haben wir es wieder, ja, wir
müssten das, wir müssten das eigentlich haben, haben wir aber nicht, ich hab's jetzt,
Leute Refreshed mal und probiert noch mal aus, ich hab's jetzt aktiviert, Way to Dank,
jawoll, ne Moment, die Animation fehlt, eigentlich sollte es eine Animation haben, oder, ach,
ich hab das falsche, Leute, ich hab das falsche geedit, ich hab das falsche geedit, ich hab
das ohne, ich brauch die Animation, haben die das irgendwie entfernt, ok, ich hab's
wieder geedit, jetzt mit Animation, testen wir noch mal, oh, jetzt hat's noch gar nicht
gecheckt, noch nicht, aber ich hab's geedit, jetzt hab ich am Better Twitch TV geedit
und Better Twitch TV checkt's noch nicht, alter, was ist hier los, ohne ordentlichen
E-Mode Support geht hier nix, eh, ja, anscheinend, ich hab's jetzt aber aktiviert, das hatten
wir auch schon mal aktiviert, ich glaub, das haben die entfernt oder das, was ich hinzugefügt
hab, hatten die entfernt, keine Ahnung, so, jetzt machen wir hier mal n bisschen zu, guck
mal hier, was hier schon wieder, ich hab hier 30 Milliarden Tabs auf, gut, so, oh man, muss
erst mal in Broggers Stimmung kommen, Leute, Gachibas, gibt's Neuigkeiten zum Job, seitdem
die Homeoffice Pflicht wieder eingeführt wurde, die wurde doch gar nicht wieder eingeführt,
es wird doch wieder nur empfohlen, das zu machen, oder, Moment, Homeoffice, das ist doch wieder
so komplettes Wischiwaschi gewesen, ach so, die Office Pflicht, ja, gut, ne, gibt's nix
Neues, wie gesagt, also, außer, dass ich garantiert nie wieder, komplette Woche irgendwie
nach Frankfurt gehe, aktuell, eins, zwei Tage die Woche, Office, und wenn das in irgendeiner
Art und Weise weiter forciert wird, bin ich weg, also, dass noch mehr, noch mehr gemacht
werden soll, Cookie, Dankeschön für den Sub, gibt es irgendwie Spezialeinstellungen
um ihn vor allem, ja, musst du, du musst, folgendes musst du machen, also, erstens solltest
du kein Gnome verwenden und auch kein KDE, vor allem nicht mit Effekten an, das funktioniert,
funktioniert auch ganz brauchbar, aber macht's unnötig langsam, am besten du verwendest
irgendwas mit Low Performance Impact, sowas wie XFCE oder so, oder wie ich, irgendwas
mit i3, und das wichtigste ist, du musst das hier einschalten, das erste Mal, du gibst
dem Ding immer ordentlich CPUs, so, und du gibst dem Ding auch immer ordentlich RAM,
also, ich hab vier CPU, kein 16GB RAM, das ist schon mal gut, und das musst du hier machen,
Accelerate 3D Graphics, und dann kannst du sowas wie Peacom oder so starten, in deiner
Linux Kiste, dann hast du auch ein bisschen Transparenz und das Ganze ist schneller, aber
das musst du auf jeden Fall, das Häkchen hier musst du auf jeden Fall setzen, glaub
das war's, mehr war's nicht, QEMU ist fucking langsam, was ganz gut ist, ist KVM, was,
ich sag mal so, Teile von QEMU verwendet, aber QEMU selbst ist wirklich das Langsamste,
was es gibt, aber ernsthaft, Desktop-Virtualisierung ist, also man darf von abgesehen, dass es
kein KVM unter Windows gibt, aber Desktop-Virtualisierung ist Forever Workstation und Virtual Box immer
noch besser, ja dann gibt der vm8 oder so, das reicht ja, hat schon mal jemand von euch
versucht mit QEMU ein Raspberry Pi zu emulieren, also quasi eine Armkiste auf x86, ich sag
euch, das ist an Langsamheit kaum zu überbieten, oh Leute irgendwie bin ich müde, ich weiß
nicht warum, als ich angefangen hab zu streamen, weil ich es noch nicht, ich muss jetzt erstmal
irgendwie, wir müssen jetzt irgendwie mich aufwecken, weil sonst ist Badge, Alter, bevor
wir anfangen, weil wenn ich müde bin, kann ich nicht gescheit nachdenken, wenn ich nicht
gescheit nachdenken kann, dann kann ich nicht keinen Brokker-Stalls machen, bist du um 18
Uhr aufgestanden?
Nee, ich nicht, ich bin ganz normal aufgestanden, halb 8, fertig, so wie immer, da selbstfalls
kein Aufwachstream gab, ja gut heute ist Samstag, morgen gibt es den Aufwachstream, ich trinke
keinen Kaffee, ich bin glaube ich der einzige Informatik-Kurs, der keinen Kaffee trinkt,
ja genau, ist Informatik Studierend Pflicht um einen Job zu finden?
Nee, ist es nicht, wer sagt denn sowas, das ist Schwachsinn, also falls das irgendjemand
erzählt hat, ist Blödsinn, muss keine Informatik studiert haben, da bist du mit Low Power x86
Kisten billiger dran, aktuell als mit Raspberry Pis, Low Power x86 Kiste, x86 Board mit drauf
gelöteter CPU, 60 Euro, Raspberry Pi 140, richtig sinnlos, warum geht Way to Dank immer
noch nicht, ich hab's geadded, es ist einfach Way to Dank, ist einfach zu
langsam, wie das geadded wird, ja 2GB ist, naja gerade mal so, ich sag mal so die 2GB
Variante, ist normalerweise kostet die Hälfte oder so, für den Preis gibt es normalerweise
die 4GB Variante, aber gut, gibt es den überhaupt bei Berry Base aktuell, das letzte Mal wo
ich geguckt hab, war eigentlich so gut wie gar nichts lieferbar, was ist mit der Seite
los, ich hatte ja mal gescheit suche hier, naja, gibt's doch gar nicht.
Gibt's doch überhaupt nicht, alles nicht verfügbar, also ich weiß nicht wie du drauf
kommst, dass es das gerade gibt, also das sieht für mich nicht so aus, als gibt es
das gerade, man muss sich in Berry Base Club anmelden, da sieht man Sachen die man nicht
auf ihrer Homepage sieht, das ist aber auch ziemlich bescheuert, die Leute wollen sich
da nicht im Club anmelden um was zu kaufen, dann kaufe ich da halt nichts, doch, doch
sind Mods da, was ist da die heutige Aufgabe, da hab ich ein Video zugemacht, guck mal,
weiß der Titel nicht, hier das da, kannst du dir angucken, das ist so, ich hab bestimmt
die Hälfte vergessen, aber das passt schon, achso, weil Modcheck, ne, sind kein Raspberry
Pi Stars, der Berry Base Club, was nicht alles gibt, ok Moment, Berry Base Club, wir melden
uns jetzt mit beim Berry Base Club an, wo geht das, Berry Base Club, das da, alter was
ist das für ne Zeit, jaja ich will Club Mitglied werden unbedingt, alles klar, Sekunde, 10
Minute Mails, also ich bin Privatkunde, Anrede, Divers, Titel, Omega, Omega, Keg, W, in die
Zwischenablage kopieren, zack, ihr Passwort, ok ich geb mal random irgendwas ein, oh mein
Gott, überprüfen die das mit dem Telefon, ich hoffe nicht, Moment, ist das hier Passwort,
ne E-Mail Adresse, achso, ihre Adresse, ok, jaja, der Maker Club, alles klar, Straße,
Cackle Street 1, 60329 Frankfurt, Hessen, Deutschland, Frankfurt, Geburtsdatum 18.10.1953, jaja schickt
mir alles, weiter, vielen Dank für eure Anmeldung, ok, noch ist nichts da, so und jetzt seh ich
was oder wie, ah haben sie gut überprüft, jaja gut, alles klar, so Maker Club, ok, ich
überprüfen es tatsächlich, ja da wird das wohl eher nix, ja gut, dann, ok, dann, ok,
dann nicht, na gut, also, dann wollen wir mal, habt ihr, achja, Chet, ich bin ja da immer
nicht so auf dem Laufenden, ich hab nur wieder heute Morgen den Fehler gemacht und hab auf
Twitter Deutschland geguckt und da war Lindner Gate am Trenden, was hat er denn angestellt,
hat er noch mal geheiratet oder was ist jetzt schon wieder los, eine Frage zu VMWare, worin
unterscheidet sich Number of Processors und Number of Corporate Processor, das ist rein
für die Optik, was die VM sieht, was du hier weiter gibst, ist die Anzahl der CPUs, die
deine VM sieht und das hier, wie viele Cores pro CPU, also wenn du zum Beispiel zwei Prozessoren
einstellst mit zwei Cores, dann siehst du in deiner VM, na gut, zwei CPUs mit jeweils
zwei Cores, also insgesamt vier, wenn du eine CPU einstellst und vier Cores, dann siehst
du auch vier Cores, allerdings nur von einer CPU, das macht nicht wirklich einen großen
Unterschied, ich stelle in der Regel immer CPU Cores ein, weil Boards und mit Multi-CPUs
so gut wie kaum im Einsatz sind und falls irgendwie deine Software trotzdem nachguckt,
ist es immer besser eine CPU mehrere Cores zuzunehmen, wegen E-Fuels, ja E-Fuels sind
nicht so beliebt, Tainser, danke schön, danke für den Sub, warum eigentlich, also Leute,
ihr wisst, ich fahre so gut wie kein Auto, mich interessiert auch das ganze Autothema
nicht wirklich großartig, was ist an E-Fuels so schlimm, ja vielleicht hat es auch irgendwelche
Vorteile, keine Ahnung, der Wirkungsgrad sackt extrem, also wenn ich das richtig im Kopf
habe, E-Fuels ist doch die Geschichte, die man quasi in normale Autos tanken kann, was
aber jetzt nicht klassische Benzinsachen sind, sondern halt hergestellt aus Strom und Zeug,
also quasi, sagt wenn ich Scheiße erzähle, kann sein, ich habe keine Ahnung von dem Thema,
also sprich, so klassischer Treibstoff für Boomer-Auto, Autos auf neue Art und Weise
hergestellt, aber guckt mal, warum ist das schlimm sich in dem Bereich irgendwie Gedanken
zu machen, also ich finde es jetzt erstmal nicht so verwerflich, also ich meine vielleicht
fällt hier irgendeinem voll das krasse Rezept für E-Fuel ein, dass das, keine Ahnung und
vor allem wenn die Energie aus erneuerbaren Energiequellen hergestellt wird, ist das doch
wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht mehr so schlecht oder, weil ich meine bis alle Autos durch
Elektroautos ersetzt sind, das wird doch auf jeden Fall noch ziemlich lange dauern, ist
für Laster und Flugzeuge gedacht, ja gerade die wirst du wahrscheinlich nie, gerade Flugzeuge
wirst du nie durch Elektroflugzeuge ersetzen gescheit, also Elektroflugzeuge funktioniert
nicht gescheit, also weiß nicht, ja gut ich weiß jetzt auch nicht was da war, aber das
klingt jetzt erstmal gar nicht so bescheuert sich damit zu beschäftigen, ja ja ich meine
es gibt doch tausende, wir wollen ins Weltall fliegen, Startups und außer SpaceX hat da
glaube ich doch keiner gescheit was hingekriegt oder wir bohren Tunneln und machen Überschall
Füge rein und sowas, ja ich wie gesagt ich kenne mich da mit null aus, aber was ist denn
wenn jetzt irgendeiner super krasse neue Verfahren findet das herzustellen, vielleicht ist das
besser, also was ich meine ist ich weiß ja nicht was die vorhaben ja, aber vielleicht
ist es sinnvoll in dem Gebiet trotzdem weiter zu gucken, ja gut das ist leider überall
so, finde ich auch kacke, an so vielen Stellen guckt euch das an mit irgendwelchen Corona
medizinischen Maskenherstellern was da gelaufen ist mit ja wir vergeben den Auftrag zufällig
an einen den wir kennen aber auch nur weil es der beste ist, ja ganz bestimmt, weil ich
glaube halt das noch ganz schön lange selbst wenn jetzt der Elektroauto Hype Train angelaufen
ist und viele neue Elektroautos sind aber also ich glaube nicht das jetzt so kurz oder lange
alles Elektroautos sein werden, ich meine die Leute die ein gut funktionierendes Auto
haben mit klassischem Motor die werden sich jetzt ja kein Elektroauto kaufen, zumal das
wahrscheinlich ja jetzt wie gesagt erzählt mir wenn ich das erzähle aber wahrscheinlich
ist die umweltschonendste Variante immer noch das alte Auto weiter zu fahren ich meine
das Ding ist schon produziert das Ding hat schon verbraucht an Ressourcen also sich ein
neues Auto kaufen kann wahrscheinlich gar nicht umweltfreundlicher sein als das alte
weiter zu benutzen bis es auseinanderfällt, ja gut dann kauft sich das ja auch wirklich
kein Mensch, naja aber wenn e-fuels dann umwelt irgendwann mal vielleicht umweltfreundlicher
werden als klassische Benzin und Diesel und Super und alles, ja das kannst du vergessen
da kommst du ja nie an, ich hab da meine Erfahrung kannst du ja knicken, ich weiß
ich hab aber es ist halt mega für den Arsch und das ist eigentlich das was mich bei dieser
ganzen Diskussion immer am meisten auf den Sack geht, dass immer nur gesagt wird so nach
dem Motto ja da müssen wir halt gucken dass der öffentliche Nahverkehr verbessert wird
es verbessert keiner was das wird seit Jahren immer beschissener, die Leute das labern
fahren selbst überhaupt nicht mit dem Zug, ja das ist natürlich beschissen das 9 Euro
Ticket sollte unbedingt da bleiben, vielleicht nicht als 9 Euro Ticket, vielleicht als keine
Ahnung 90 Euro Ticket, 90 Euro für deutschlandweit wäre immer noch viel billiger als was die
meisten Leute an Monatskarten kaufen, 90 Euro deutschlandweit wäre richtig Pog, ja sowas
ist gut, das ist dann das scheitert aber ich finde es muss deutschlandweit sein weil das
scheitert sonst oder 69 Euro Ticket das wäre gut, weil sonst scheitert das wieder bei Leuten
die bei mir ja um die Ecke in Bayern wohnen und zwei Stationen durch Bayern fahren müssen
und den Rest nach Hessen zu Frankfurt und so, das ist wieder unglaublich Bürokratie
und behaftet, deswegen 90 Euro deutschlandweit scheiß drauf fertig, dann benutzen das die
Leute auch mal und vielleicht merkt dann auch mal ein Großteil der Bevölkerung was für
absolut bodenlose Frecher und was für bodensatz die Bahn ist und dann tut sich vielleicht
mal irgendwann was, ich glaube ohne mehr Druck aus der Bevölkerung tut sich da nichts, meint
ihr, jetzt mal blöd, meint ihr, meint ihr, die Bahn, das Bahnmanagement, sagen wir mal
so mittleres, oberes Bahnmanagement, Vorstand, Führungskräfte und so, meint ihr die fahren
mit der Bahn zur Arbeit, die die können, ernsthaft jetzt, weil ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen
ehrlich gesagt, also da wo ich fahre geht nichts mit der Bahn, kannst du knicken, das
ist das falsche Projekt, das ist pepo fetter, wir wollen nicht pepo fetter aufmachen, wir
wollen den postchamp aufmachen, der muss postchampen, postchamping, kannst du ja auch nicht machen,
du fährst ja auf den Gleisen von der deutschen Bahn, das ist ja das Problem, es gibt ja Sachen
wie Flixtrain oder bei uns die hessische Landesbahn oder so Trittanbieter, die aber die Gleise
benutzen und das ist das eigentliche Problem, spukige Musik, viel zu spukig, privat Gleise,
das hat noch keiner gemacht bisher, das wird auch die nächsten 40 Jahre dann wahrscheinlich
nix, ich sehe das übrigens genau, sehe ich übrigens auch so, es muss deutlich mehr persönliches
Interesse her, der Bahnmanagements die Sache ordentlich zu managen, das muss ganz klar
persönliche Interessen daran hängen und sei es nur, dass man seinen Job behält, ja guck
mal in die Schweiz, da funktioniert das auch besser, das funktioniert eigentlich in allen
Ländern mit Geld besser als bei uns und es ist ja nicht als hätten wir zu wenig Geld,
wie gesagt ich kann es nicht oft genug sagen, wir sind zumindest was Wirtschaft angeht das
viertreichste Land der Welt, aber im Moment Leute wir müssen uns ja aktuell Gedanken
drüber machen, dass wir nicht frieren müssen im Winter, ich kann es vergessen, als viertreichstes
Land der Welt kann es schon mal passieren, dass man frieren muss im Winter, das ist tatsächlich,
das habe ich auch gelesen und die Telekom verdient angeblich richtig fett Geld in den
USA mit, weiß ich, ist es Mobilfunk, keine Ahnung, mit Zeug, die sollen alle mal ihren
Scheiß zusammen kriegen und hierfür ordentliche Infrastruktur sorgen, das geht mir mega auf
den Sack, dass du dir hier teilweise vorkommst, wie irgendwie in einem dritten Weltland was
Infrastruktur angeht, Müsli, danke schön für den Zap, so aber jetzt mal zu etwas erfreulicheren
Themen, wir basteln jetzt, wir basteln jetzt ein bisschen Go weiter und ich habe festgestellt,
als ich mir mal so Gedanken gemacht habe gestern über Go, es ist ja schön und gut, wenn man
hier irgendwie so Skriptartig, warum ist denn da hinten so ein, aber ich das minimiert habe,
es ist ja schön und gut, wenn man solche Skriptartigen Dinger basteln kann, aber wie
würde man denn jetzt zum Beispiel eine Klasse mit unterschiedlichen Methoden machen in Go,
ich glaube das müssen wir uns mal angucken, also in Go scheint das ja nicht zu funktionieren,
ja Structs und dann Zeug, das müssen wir mal ausbringen, ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung
wie das geht und wenn man sagt Go Lang OOP, da findet man zum größten Teil sehr merkwürdige
Beispiele, so irgendwas was ich sehr komisch liest und ich bin nicht so sicher, ob das
so funktioniert, ich habe mir gedacht wir könnten ja mal versuchen diese API hier zu
rappen, die wir hier verwenden, also sowas hier zum Beispiel, Type, Alert Manager, API,
Struct und jetzt hört es schon auf, jetzt weiß ich nicht mehr wie es weiter geht, ok
Name, String, ok da kann man dann sowas reinschreiben wie, 100 Milliarden Bits, Dankeschön
Schattenwellen für den Sub, äh nicht für den Sub, für die Bits, Pong, oh guck mal
hier gibt es ein Tutorial, excellent, excellent, der Chat weiß Bescheid, also what, Moment
ich versuche das mal kurz zu übersetzen, also Alert Manager, warum sind manche, guck mal
Leute das verstehe ich nicht, Sachen wie FMT, die sind klein geschrieben, aber jetzt hier
werden Typen groß geschrieben, was ist denn Convention so, also schreibt man das groß,
schreibt man das klein, wobei wartet mal da war doch was, da war doch was, das war doch
irgendwie ein Unterschied, wenn ich das richtig in Go habe, genau, groß ist exported, stimmt,
stimmt, ja ja ich erinnere mich, also machen wir hier Alert Manager, API, Struct, Ull,
so und jetzt kann ich, wie mache ich denn einen Constructor in, also hier guck mal sowas
zum Beispiel, die Errors, New, so wie kriege ich so eine Art Constructor hin, also was
ich vor habe ist, ich will dann sowas hier machen können, guck mal, ich will dann sowas
machen können wie API, Get, Silences, so und vorher will ich machen API, Doppelpunkt, Alert
Manager, so was hier, New, Alert Manager, API, aber das gibt es nicht, das gibt es nicht,
also ich weiß, dass man, dass man dann irgendwie sowas hier machen muss, aber gemacht habe
ich das noch nicht, also so, Alert Manager, der Chat weiß Bescheid, ich copy paste jetzt
einfach aus dem Chat, easy, Chat copy pasting, beste, aber das war weg, As Manager, achso,
das ist hier die Variable, wie das intern heißt, so, dann wahrscheinlich so, also dann sage
ich sowas wie String, so, ne oder, return, ne, so funktioniert das schon mal nicht oder,
muss ich das, muss ich das return, muss ich das irgendwie so, ok und jetzt, und jetzt kann
ich machen was, Alert Manager, API, ne, ne, ach, ahja, ahja, ok, verstehe, String, Kackel,
fertig, ne, doch, ne, was, hä, wie nicht genug Argumente, aber nur eins, hä, wait a minute,
ich muss Alert Manager übergeben, um einen Alert Manager zu bekommen, muss ich, muss
ich irgendwie, muss ich irgendwie, what the fuck, das change nicht new, so, so, ne oder,
das kann doch nicht in den Ernst sein, ne, ne oder, das, ne, Moment, das muss ich jetzt,
go lang constructor, was ich prokramiere ist ein Tool, wo du, ähm, muss ich dir, muss
ich dir zeigen, ach, muss ich erst mal starten, Leute, ich glaube, ich, das wird heute nichts,
ich bin heute nicht irgendwie geistig so zurechnungsfähig, dass ich sinnvoll was machen kann, ne, ne,
ich glaube, das wird heute nichts, aber ich kann dir erklären, was ich mache, also, bei
uns auf der Arbeit ist öfters das Problem, also stell dir vor, du machst Wartungsarbeiten
auf einem System und es ist ja so, dass wenn du Systeme hast im Enterprise Business Umfeld,
diese Systeme werden ja überwacht, meistens automatisch von irgendeiner Monitoring Software,
das heißt, wenn das System kaputt geht, bekommt man das mit und nicht erst, wenn dich irgendeiner
auf der Hotline anruft und sagt, Alter, warum geht dein Service nicht mehr, was bei uns
jetzt oftmals das Problem ist, dass die Leute, wenn sie Wartungsarbeiten an dem System machen,
vergessen das Monitoring auszuschalten oder Silence reinzustellen, dass es nicht anschlägt
für das System, auf dem sie Wartungsarbeiten machen, Python Version anfangen, oh ne Leute,
ich weiß nicht, was wir heute machen, ich kann irgendwie nicht denken gerade, man müsste
das in ein neues Package auslagern, das erinnert einen dran, naja, es erinnert einen nicht
wirklich dran, es macht es einfach, von der Kiste selbst sowas zu setzen, da musst du
nicht erst anrufen oder in Webinterface oder so, wir haben ja auch schon was, was funktioniert,
ja, ich habe eine.NET Variante davon, die funktioniert ohne Probleme, oh ne, ich glaube,
ich kann noch nichts machen, ich kriege heute nichts auf die Reihe, ich merke, dass es gibt
so Tage, da habe ich nichts, kann ich mich nicht konzentrieren, habe irgendwie nichts
im Kopf, um sinnvoll was zu machen, ich weiß nicht, gibt es irgendwas auf YouTube, was man
gucken könnte, GpnEasy VPN, WireGuard wahrscheinlich, PowerShell Syntax, ja PowerShell Syntax ist
für Automatisierung ganz nice, aber für interaktive Shell gefällt mir PowerShell überhaupt nicht,
ne Leute, wir machen morgen früh aufwachen Stream, ich mache jetzt, ich streame jetzt
nicht weiter, ich kann mich heute nicht konzentrieren auf irgendwas, funktioniert nicht, ich bin
auch nicht motiviert, das ist komisch, ich habe den Stream angeschmissen, habe mir gedacht,
auf geht's, aber jetzt habe ich irgendwie keinen Bock, ich weiß nicht, eh, ein Battlefield,
soll man ein Battlefield spielen 2042 oder was, ganz bestimmt nicht 2042, zu wenig Eisen,
ja vielleicht, Amazon hat es heute wieder richtig verkackt, was Serien und so angeht,
guckt mal, ich wollte heute morgen eine neue Folge gucken, Serie, hier, also die aktuelle
Folge dieser Serie läuft bei den Amis, immer Donnerstars glaube ich, 21 da war das, ja
also am 21.
lief das bei den Amis, normalerweise schaltet Amazon neue Folgen, Freitag, Vormittags frei
zu, die haben es jetzt tatsächlich geschafft, dass ich die Season gekauft habe, aber Amazon
sagt, der Season Pass geht dafür irgendwie nicht, was auch immer, das für eine bescheuerte
Logik ist, so und dann habe ich mich beschwert, dann hat Amazon geantwortet, Amazon hatte tatsächlich
da drauf geantwortet, ach du dumm, den Typ habe ich gemutet, den Typ habe ich gemutet,
deswegen lese ich den Scheiß nicht, denn er schreibt, so, genau, sie haben gesagt hier,
sie geben das weiter, die Serie ist übrigens immer noch nicht da, und dann kam mir noch
der Hit, ich habe dann, weil Folge 7 habe ich noch nicht geguckt, ich habe dann Folge
7 angemacht und habe festgestellt, Folge 7 ist eigentlich Folge 8, das heißt, es fehlen
Folge 7, was im Endeffekt bedeutet, die Leute haben 7 Tage jetzt oder quasi 14 Tage auf
eine neue Folge gewartet, weil letzte Woche Folge 7 nicht kam, also Amazon ist wirklich
unfähig, was diese Videosachen angeht, demnächst doch wieder Pirate Bay Gaggle, nee, ich habe
schon lange nichts mehr gelernt über Tochen und sonst was, ich habe es eigentlich auch
nicht vor, aber manchmal, manchmal lassen sie einem echt keine andere Wahl, ja, ist
echt so, ich will ja gar nicht, aber was soll ich machen, er weiß, dass die richtige Folge
ist ja, ja es gibt neues Level Cap, das gucken wir uns morgen an, ich stelle mal kurz den
Titel um, solange ich jetzt Just Chatting, bleibe ich noch ein paar Minuten an, mal gucken,
Titel geändert, Leute, wenn ihr um irgendwas schwätzen wollt, sagt Bescheid, ich bin
halt so unmotiviert, irgendwas mit Gehirnanstrengungen zu machen, eigentlich müsste ich jetzt mal
irgendwie kurz hier ums Haus rennen oder so, dass ich wieder wach bin, aber das habe ich
jetzt auch keinen Bock drauf, welches Video, hier guck das da, achso, oh nein, die Adresse
wurde gelöscht, bin ich freigeschaltet für den Maker Club, fuck, ey, haben die mich
gekickt, Moment, wait a minute, ne, Willkommen Keck, passt doch, ey, ey, ich glaube die haben
meinen Account disabled, weil Fake E-Mail Adresse, die waren aber schnell, ne, doch nicht, schon
mal eine Fallstudio für eine Bewerbung gemacht, ey, was genau, was soll, ich muss ein bisschen
genauer erklären, der Maker Club, ach ne, ich bekomme noch nicht funktioniert, ja, Debian
ist zu alt als Desktop Betriebssystem, achso, ne, das muss ich ja nicht machen, was sind
das denn so für Aufgaben, sag mal, was musstest du machen so ganz grob, ich mein, die sollen
da einfach ganz verdammt sind, einen
Wörten, ja der Klassiker.
Erklären Sie Active Directory in 15 Minuten, proprietärer Microsoft Shit den Microsoft
und Business Enterprise Leute gut finden.
Neues Feature wurde ausgerollt und neuer Kunde will mehr aber keine.
Das ist doch ganz einfach, dann soll er mehr bezahlen, dann gibt es auch Kapazität.
Und wenn er nicht bezahlen will, dann macht man was anderes.
Easy, genau, einfach Geld, ja muss man ja auch nicht, man muss keine Leute einstellen.
Der muss einfach mehr bezahlen als die anderen, dann arbeitet man an seinem Problem weiter.
Kann jemand das mit dem Binary Tree erklären?
Ja das ist so eine 0815, mittlerweile ist das schon das richtige Meme geworden, was in Vorstellungsgesprächen
dran kommt und eines dieser typischen Probleme, was auch immer gememt wird, ist eben Binary
Tree Inverten.
Zu deutsch, ein Binärbaum wahrscheinlich, vermute ich mal, ja ein Binärbaum geht es
darum, das ist eine Datenstruktur mit mehreren Knoten, wo jeder Knoten maximal 2 unter Knoten
haben kann, Kinder tatsächlich, Kindernote, Childnote haben kann.
Ich glaube die richtige Lösung ist, dass man das eskalieren lassen soll bei seinem
eigenen Chef, ja klar, man selbst kann es ja eh nicht entscheiden.
Was für ein Job war das denn, wo sowas gefragt wird?
Ich finde das immer bescheuert, wenn das so aus der Luft gegriffene Dinge sind, das sind
wie dann so Fragen, wo sehen sie sich in 10 Jahren und so ein Blödsinn, Software Ingenieur.
Wisst ihr was, ich hätte gesagt, das soll jemand anderes entscheiden, das ist nicht
mal ein Bier, genau, das ist wie gesagt, deswegen wird das ja auch immer als Beispiel gebracht,
die Beine die 3 inverten, oh Mann Leute, ich bin echt im Arsch, ich weiß nicht warum,
also wer denkt, heute kommt die richtig FyFat-Content, kommt nicht, ich bin jetzt noch viertel Stunde
an oder so und dann gucke ich irgendwie Serie oder Spiel, Steam, irgendwas oder keine Ahnung,
ich finde das richtig nice, ich meine das Spielkonzept an sich ist jetzt wirklich nicht
das innovativste, du läufst rum und suchst irgendwie NPC A, sucht Item B und NPC C hat
Item B, möchte aber was von NPC A und ja das ist jetzt, das ist eher so ein Entspannungsgame,
das kann ich jetzt nicht spielen, wenn ich das jetzt spiele, schlafe ich nämlich ein
dabei.
Ja das habe ich auch schon öfters gesehen, dass es gerade größere Unternehmen in Deutschland
gibt oder aber auch kleine Klitschen, die meinen sie wären das nächste Google, suchen
eigentlich überhaupt nicht Leute wie Google, können auch nichts bieten wie Google, aber
machen auf Google, weder noch aktuell so gut wie gar nichts, ne es gibt nichts, es gibt
ja nichts, oh schlimm heute, ganz schlimm, ich würde gerne mal einen sinnvollen Vergleich
sehen zwischen US-Deaf-Gehältern, ich meine das muss nicht Google und Netflix sein, ja
so mal so 0815 US-Deaf-Gehälter versus 0815 Deutschland-Deaf-Gehälter, allerdings richtig
gerechnet mit Krankenversicherung und sowas, da könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass sie dort
auch gar nicht so viel mehr verdienen.
Also wenn man den Kram abzieht dort, den wir hier auch abgezogen bekommen, vielleicht
nicht in dem ganzen Umfang, ja würde ich auch so schätzen, ich würde auch sagen es ist
immer noch mehr, aber es ist jetzt nicht so krass wie das teilweise aussieht, wenn du
dann irgendwie hörst Amazon-Senior-Ding 250.000 Euro oder so, du hast sowas zu tun ja, man
kann es ja sogar in München von wohnen, wobei das wahrscheinlich auch drauf ankommt wo
das ist, ja, weiß nicht ob es dort auch den Trend gibt bisschen mehr aufs Land zu gehen,
bei uns gibt es das ja seit ein paar Jahren, so seit, eigentlich seit Corona so richtig,
es gibt so ein kleines CAF, da laufe ich beim Wandern öfters durch, das besteht zu 50%
aus neuen Häusern, also dieses CAF besteht wirklich aus einer Straße, ich kann es euch
zeigen, Google Maps, Klein Hemsbach, das hört sich auch so an, so, da wandere ich öfters
mal hier in der Region ja und da laufe ich öfters durch und dieses Dorf, also meist
läuft man dann so hier so durch oder nach da oben oder hier außen, zumindest dieses
CAF das besteht zu 50% aus neuen Häusern, weiß gar nicht ob man das überhaupt erkennt,
das hat nur eine Straße ja, das ist die einzige Straße hier und man erkennt das, wartet mal
Leute, wie ging das nochmal, wie konnte man, ne ich brauche, ich brauche Google Earth 3D
brauche ich, Moment das muss ich aber in Google Chrome machen, Earth 3D, ok, Membris, so und
ich hoffe man kann da kippen, also hier sieht man, also man sieht, was konnte man noch irgendwie
so kippen das ganze, also man sieht das liegt hier schon ein bisschen in den Bergen ja,
sieht man ja hier und davon sind, ohne Mist, man erkennt es glaube ich hier so ein bisschen
an den Baustellen, davon sind 50% der Häuser, das ist übrigens das falsche, das hier so
richtig so klein Hemsbach, so hier laufe ich dann durch so manchmal von hier unten so hoch
und 50% der Häuser, man sieht das hier auch teilweise an den Dächern und so, das ist
alles neu und da sind die ganzen Leute von der Umgebung glaube ich hier hergezogen, ich
gehe davon aus, wäre ich hier vor 5 Jahren durchgelaufen, wären wahrscheinlich einfach
so gut wie keine Häuser da gewesen und jetzt ist die ganze Straße voll, aber 50% neue
Häuser, also es ziehen viele Leute jetzt weg seit Homeoffice möglich ist, in so unter
anderem so kleine Dinger, ey da gibt es ordentliches Internet wenigstens ja, ist aber nice, es ist
richtig am Arsch der Welt, es ist richtig am Arsch der Welt, Supermarkt gibt es da auch
kein, also ich laufe meistens so, ich parke irgendwo hier unten, laufe dann hier lang,
laufe dann hier so den Berg hoch, Wanderstrecke liegt Leute, laufe dann hier so den Berg
hoch, laufe dann hier so den Berg hoch, ok das ist verbackt, Berg hoch und dann hier
hinten durch den Wald zurück so, ja gut so siehts aus, aber mit Aldi und Lidl, ne der
ist bald bisschen weiter weg, bin seit Corona auch im Homeoffice und wohne jetzt auf dem
Land, ja kenne ich auch ein paar die das gemacht haben, also ich glaube das Kaff durch das
ich durchlaufe das hat glaube ich irgendwie 80 Einwohner oder so, also nix, dafür kann
man da schön wandern und ich stelle es mir für Homeoffice wirklich cool vor, du wohnst
ein bisschen draußen, es ist kein Krach, es gehen hier keine Leute auf den Sack, du kannst
draußen rumlaufen, sieht schön aus und rein kannst du ins Haus, machst du Homeoffice und
verdienst Geld, das ist Pog, haben alle was von, ja dies ist immer noch die gleiche ich
habe da seit Jahren nix dran gemacht, ne also das stelle ich mir schon nice vor, ich meine
ich kann mich jetzt hier auch nicht beschweren, bei mir ist es halt so, ich wohne jetzt halt
nicht wirklich auf dem Land, ich wohne aber jetzt auch nicht in der Großstadt, ich wohne
so am Rand ein bisschen, dafür ist bei mir halt der Bahnhof in der Nähe, das ist natürlich
auch super.
Gunray, Dankeschön für den Sub, Leute wie gesagt also wer Big Brain Content heute erwartet
wird hier nix finden, ja könnte man so sagen, ne es ist nicht wirklich die Vorstadt, es
ist ein anderer Stadtteil, bisschen weiter, bisschen außerhalb, aber es ist praktisch,
du bist relativ schnell in Frankfurt und du hast aber ein bisschen mehr deine Ruhe als
in Frankfurt, meinst du man kann sich irgendwie auf die Ausbildung vorbereiten, naja das einfachste
ist, hast du schon eine Ausbildungsstelle, wahrscheinlich ne, das einfachste ist dir
mal anzugucken was die in dem Betrieb machen, wo du hingehst und dich dann dort ein bisschen
vorbereiten, also was weiß ich, wenn die sagen, hey wir machen total viele, wir haben total
viele Linux Server, dass du dich da ein bisschen Linux Thematik einliest, so rein im Vakuum
ohne, kann man da wenig sagen, also raus bekommen was die so machen, wer nicht verkehrt und
du kannst dir tatsächlich den Plan von der Berufsschule angucken, wobei naja Berufsschule
halt, ja, Berufsschule kannst du eh vergessen, mit Mac, was ist das für ein Laden, welcher
IT Ladender arbeitet hauptsächlich mit Mac, Hipster Web Designer vielleicht, auf der anderen
Seite ganz im Ernst, warum nicht, eigentlich ist es gar nicht blöd mit Macs zu arbeiten,
wenn du nämlich keinen Bock auf Windows Shit hast und dich nicht mit Linux auf dem Desktop
rumschlagen willst, was ich verstehen kann, bleibt ja eigentlich nur Mac, wenn man was
haben will, was irgendwie halbwegs modern ausschaut und alle nötigen Command Line Tools
und Sachen hat, da bleibt ja eigentlich nur Mac, deswegen, ja, ich glaube nicht, dass
du Server-Site Rendering meinst, was machst du denn, es ist blöd, dass alle abkürzt und
mittlerweile schon 5-fach belegt sind, ne Server-Sites Rendering ist SSR, das habe ich jetzt durcheinander
gebracht, ja, kann ich verstehen, ich schlage mich gerade damit rum, wie wir unsere ganzen,
wie es heute so modern heißt, Infrastructure as Code, Repos umgezogen bekommen auf GitHub,
das Problem ist, wir haben da wirklich zehntausende Sachen drinnen über die letzten Jahre angesammelt,
ich weiß, wir haben immer noch 3000 Linux-Server plus den ganzen Cloud-Krempel und das Problem
ist, da steht an jeder Ecke, steht ein Passwort, steht ein Zertifikat, steht irgendein Secret,
ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wie ich das auf GitHub umgezogen bekommen soll jemals, es
geht einzig und allein erstmal darum, nur das Repo überhaupt erstmal zu pushen zu GitHub,
ich meine, das ist nicht Public, ja, noch wär ja noch schöner, das ist nicht Public,
aber sie haben sich überlegt, dass sie in GitHub keine Rechte verwalten wollen, also
die gesamte Firma mit GitHub Accounts kann alle Repos sehen, nee, nee, nee, so einfach
ist das nicht, das Repo um das es geht, da stehen Secrets drinnen überall und keiner
weiß genau wo, das ist ein riesen Repo mit Ansible und Puppet Code, was sich seit 10
Jahren angesammelt hat für alle unsere Systeme, Leute, an jeder Ecke stehen Secrets, die keiner
mehr erkennt, jaja, du musst den Kram erstmal finden, das ist das Problem, du kannst ja
nicht einfach nach Passwort suchen, also ich hab jetzt schon mehrere probiert, ich hab
zwei Repo-Analyse-Tools laufen lassen, die dir dann so Sachen ausgeben wie, ja, das ist
ein String, der sieht random aus, das könnte ein Passwort sein und Leute, ich glaube ich
hab noch 800, über 800 Stellen gefunden, wo Zertifikate, Secrets und Geschiss drin steht,
das krieg ich da im Leben nicht raus, von unserer Git-History gar nicht mal zu reden,
die kann ich, die muss ich eh wegschmeißen, da steht zu viel drin, das kann sogar sein,
dass ich das benutzt hab, ne, ne, das ist was anderes, ne, ne, ich hab, aufbei, ich bin
mir nicht sicher, ich hab zwei Analyse-Tools laufen lassen, eins hatte auch so in dem Drehsterne,
es könnte das sogar gewesen sein und das hat massig Zeug gefunden, ja, das muss da irgendwie
alles raus, also es ist weniger nicht, es ist nicht das Problem, wenn man die gefunden
hat, die auszulagern, das Problem ist die zu finden und irgendeinen zu finden, der
für das Auslagern zuständig ist, weil ich kann das ja nicht von Hand machen, ja oder
neuer Job, ne, ich kann das nicht von Hand machen, weil da hängt ja teilweise die Maintenance
von Systemen dran, das muss dann schon derjenige machen, der für die Systeme zuständig ist,
was reingeschrieben wurde und boah, ich werd das auch so machen, ne, ich werd, ich werd
die History nicht squashen, ich werd einfach den Git-Ordner löschen und ein initiales
neues Commit machen und dann pushen nach GitHub ohne History, weil in der History stehen
viel zu viele Passwörter drinnen über die letzten zehn Jahre und sicherlich Passwörter,
die auch noch in Verwendung sind, das ist eh so ein Ding, so ist es halt in Business
Enterprise, Stonks Umfeld, Legacy, soweit das Auge reicht, Site Reliable Engineering,
achja, irgendwie hab ich mit Server-Site Rendering durcheinander gebracht, achja, ey das Repo
ist so alt, da existiert das Wort DevOps noch nicht mal, immer ganz davon abgesehen,
da hindert dich auch keiner dran, irgendein Zertifikat in dein Repo zu legen und zu committen,
gibt halt Leute, die machen das und das war ja an sich, solange das alles intern war gar
nicht so problematisch, ich mein, wenn du irgendeinen Ansible-Script hast, weil der
Webserver ein Zertifikat braucht, ja gut, irgendwo muss es herkommen und solange das
alles intern ist, ist es ja prinzipiell gar nicht so schlimm, dass es geht, Repo zu committen,
problematisch ist nur, wenn du es halt jetzt nach GitHub pushen sollst, also vielleicht
ist es, ich kenn eure Entwickler nicht, aber ich hatte letztens eine Begegnung mit einem
Entwickler von uns, da denk ich mir, es ist besser, dass der kein Ops macht, Riesenstreiterei,
ich glaub ich hab's schon mal im Stream erzählt, Riesenstreiterei, weil irgendeine App nicht
mehr ging und es hat sich dann rausgestellt, die App ging nicht mehr, weil die checken nicht
nur, ob das Zertifikat gültig ist, die haben das Zertifikat gepinnt, also die gucken auch,
ob der Herausgeber der richtige ist, ja kann man machen, okay, ist aber nur dumm, wenn
es schon seit eigentlich zwei Jahren oder so die Ansage gibt, dass man von dieser CA
nix mehr holen soll und so weit wie möglich alles über Let's Encrypt macht, also was
haben unsere Leute gemacht, Eingangs Zertifikate umgestellt auf Let's Encrypt und auf einmal
ging die App nicht mehr und alle so, hä, warum geht die App nicht mehr, bis denn irgendeiner
drauf gekommen ist und hat sich das mal angeguckt und dann festgestellt, naja klar, der Herausgeber
des Zertifikats ist jetzt ein anderer, so und darauf hin wurde Emergency gemietet mit
dem Appteam und da war ein Entwickler drin, der hat dann wirklich gesagt, also ich gebe
zu, ich hab mich vielleicht ein bisschen genervt angehört auf die Meeting, aber trotzdem,
der hat gemeint, so sinngemäß, ich krieg's, lass mal kurz überlegen, wie hat er das gesagt,
jaja, Moment, ich krieg das gar nicht mehr richtig zusammen, also wir haben ihm erzählt,
das alte Zertifikat ist abgelaufen, ja, und wir müssen das tauschen, weil ansonsten ist
in zwei Wochen der gesamte Eingang halt nicht mehr verfügbar und darauf hin meinte der
dann so, ja wie abgelaufen, abgelaufen, das Zertifikat ist bis 2035 gültig, da hab ich
dann gemeint, nein, das Zertifikat ist, ich glaub ich hab mich mehr oder weniger in so
genau diesem Tonfall angehört, ich glaub das hat ihn auch geärgert, hat er ja auch
recht, ja trotzdem, das ging mir, ich war schon echt genervt, ich hab dann halt gemeint,
nein, das ist nicht bis 2035 gültig, das ist abgelaufen, das läuft 14 Tagen ab, deswegen
haben wir's getauscht, das ist nicht bis 2035 gültig, doch, das ist bis 2035 gültig, er
hat's doch grade vor sich, nein, das ist nicht bis 2035 gültig, bis 2035, bis 2035 gültig
ist das Zertifikat von der CA, die uns das ausgestellt haben, aber nicht das Zertifikat
selber, und der hat bis zum Schluss dieser Besprechung darauf beharrt, dass das Zertifikat
nicht abläuft und bis 2035 gültig ist, ich weiß nicht was mit den Leuten los ist, also
da ist es besser, da ist es tatsächlich lieber, ich kann mir aber nicht vorstellen, weißt
du, was ich mich frage ist, Leute die damit schon Probleme haben, das können doch auch
keine guten Entwickler sein, gute Entwickler sind Leute mit technischem Knowhow, ich mein,
die brauchen keine 20 Jahre Linux Erfahrung, aber so ein bisschen drumherum, ist doch eigentlich
allein schon, weil man sich dafür interessiert, müsste doch so ein bisschen Verständnis dafür
da sein, ohne ein bisschen Interesse dafür da sein, was da noch so drumherum passiert,
also ich denke, das gibt es nicht, ich weiß nicht, man kann es mir zumindest nicht vorstellen,
dass man ein guter Entwickler sein kann, aber sich für links und rechts neben seinen Sachen
für nichts aus der Technik interessiert, ja das kann ich mir vorstellen, du meinst,
weil ich so viel Cobol Erfahrung habe, na gut, man muss ja mal sagen, Leute, ungelogen,
ich hab bestimmt mehr Cobol Erfahrung als 99% aller, ok ich sag noch nicht mal aller Menschen
auf der Welt, ich hab mehr Cobol Erfahrung als 99% aller Leute, die in der IT arbeiten,
das meine ich ernst, ich mein ich hab immerhin schon mal mit Cobol was gemacht, 99% der Leute
mit Sicherheit nicht, aber Cobol Programmierer möchte ich definitiv nie werden, ja es ist
teilweise schon schlimm, aber es ist umgedreht auch so, ich sehe da auch genug Leute, die
eigentlich für Infrastruktur und so verantwortlich sind, die da auch keinen Plan von dem haben,
auf was es ankommt, dass eben die Anwendungen da drauf ordentlich laufen, es ist merkwürdig,
zum Beispiel wir haben relativ viele Java Anwendungen, und es gibt Leute, die checken es heute immer
noch nicht, wenn irgendein Entwickler sagt, ob man mal die Startparameter ändern könnte,
weil das Ding braucht irgendwie mehr, oh ich hab vergessen wie es bei Java heißt, XMSS,
ne wie heißt der Krempel bei Java, das braucht mehr Speicher beim Start schon allocated,
weiß nicht wie das genau bei Java heißt, und die checken das bis heute nicht, denen
musst du das immer wieder neu erklären, also es gibt, es ist halt wie überall, 90% der
Leute sind unfähig, ja und auch nur weil sie den Beruf ausüben, heißt das noch lange
nicht, dass sie fähig sind, was ist an Chromium besser, es ist nicht, es ist Chrome ohne ein
paar Google Teile, ja eigentlich ist es schlechter als Chrome, weil es hat mancher Hardware Beschleunigungs
Sachen nicht, ich hab das nur genommen, weil ich kein Chromecast eingebaut haben wollte,
ja und kein Sync und kein Google Software Reporting Tool und so ein Shit, ja kann sein
wie gesagt, das sieht gut aus ja, hat kein Text zu Speech, gut hab ich keinen Anwendungszweck
für, Firefox hab ich auch, also ich benutze Chromium, Chrome und Firefox und Edge hab
ich genotgetrunken installiert, aber ich verwende kein Edge, ich mein, wer verwendet schon Edge,
ich weiß jetzt sagen Leute im Chat wieder, ja ich, ich verwende Edge, es gibt tatsächlich
Leute die Edge verwenden, ich weiß und jetzt werd ich gleich wieder versuchen zu bekehren
so nach dem Motto, der neue Edge ist gar nicht so schlecht, übrigens wenn ihr mal getriggerte
Linux Fans sehen wollt, seht ihr mal ein bisschen die Kommentare unter meinem letzten Video
für euch angucken, ok ich geb zu vielleicht etwas provokanter Titel, aber der Titel ist
ja im Prinzip das worüber ich rede im Video und zumindest wenn ihr paar getriggerte Linux
Fans sehen wollt, dann müsst ihr hier nochmal durchgucken, die meisten Leute sind ja normal,
aber hier auch getriggerte Linux Fan, ist das das wo ich am rumschreien bin?
Ja gut, da konnte man sich schon mal ein bisschen aufregen.
Ja Rust bringt einen zur Verzweiflung, wählst du dein Chromium unter Windows aktuell, das
hat nen Updater dabei, der startet und dir sagt wenn es eine neue Version gibt, dann
musst du auf Download klicken, wenn die neue Version da ist.
Oh man, ey Rust lass ich erst mal bleiben, da dreh ich auf komplett durch bei Omega
Keg, oh ich wollt grad Licht einschalten über mein Home Automation System und stell fest
die Batterie von meinem Fritz Thermostat ist leer, obwohl es eindeutig nicht leer ist,
weil ich guck gerade drauf, was sagen, da hat irgendwie die Synchronisation nicht so
funktioniert wie sie sollte, ja Rust ist echt so ein Sache für sich, ja die Deckdinger,
ich hab einiges ausprobiert, ich hab ZigBee Thermostate ausprobiert und ich hab auch einen
Siebel Thermostat ausprobiert und die Fritz Deckdinger, die funktionieren tatsächlich
am besten, leider sind sie nicht so ganz billig.
Ich gehör auch zu den Open Source Leuten und ich find Rust eigentlich vom Ansatz her
auch mega geil, also Rust ist für den Einsatzzweck, wo es ursprünglich gedacht wurde, glaub ich
das beste was es gibt, man muss sich ja überlegen, das Ding wurde von Mozilla erfunden, also
von den Firefox Leuten und im Hinblick auf das, dass sie quasi Browser Sicherheitslücken
vermeiden wollen und trotzdem was schnelles haben wollen, für solche Anwendungsgebiete
ist Rust gut, also was was sicherer sein soll, allerdings auch schnell und das in Kombination
ist wirklich cool, mir fällt keine andere Sprache ein die das so gut hinkriegt wie Rust,
leider ist Rust was Syntax angeht und Komplexität auch schon total am ausufern, allerdings auf
andere Art und Weise wie C++, Rust ist in gewisser Weise nachvollziehbar, du verstehst
meistens warum es meckert, dir fällt aber jetzt so spontan dann manchmal nichts ein
wie du es machen könntest, dass es nicht total ausufert an Komplexität, bei C++ ist
es einfach so, dass es nur noch wir ist und du überhaupt nicht weißt was die sich dabei
gedacht haben, Network Chuck guck ich nicht gerne, so Hipster Zeug, der Rust Compiler ist
deutlich netter als der C++ Compiler, der C++ Compiler wirft dir nämlich 40 Zeilen Fehlermeldungen
aus und du weißt nicht woran es liegt, im Rust Compiler weißt du es meistens, Tado,
ja Tado habe ich zum Glück damals geschickt um Shift, nee kein C++ Rant heute, ja das
nervt mich, also ich habe nicht viel mit Rust gemacht aber das nervt mich auch, also du
brauchst ja wirklich für jeden Furz externe Packages, also wo es bei mir wirklich aufgehört
hat ist, dass du mit Rust noch nicht mal eine Timespan parsen konntest, also Rust hat nichts
eingebautest um eine Duration zu parsen from String, du musst das selbst programmieren
oder einen Package verwenden, einen Crate verwenden, ich meine ist es zu viel verlangt
dass es Duration Punkt Pars gibt, anscheinend, bloatet, braucht man nicht, ich glaube sogar
C++ hat sowas, schauen wir mal, ja aber passt mal auf es ist hässlich, all diese Chrono
APN C++ ist glaube ich eines der menschenverachtendsten Sachen die ich je gesehen habe, Moment Example,
der Stelle gehts noch, passt mal auf ich zeige euch jetzt mal was, ich zeige euch jetzt mal
was, ich zeige euch jetzt mal was, das geht noch viel schlimmer, das geht noch viel schlimmer,
mein Go-Projekt, ich habe heute nichts gemacht, ich wollte heute eigentlich weitermachen,
ich gucke da hin, Alter wenn ich sowas hier schon sehe, aber C++ ist eh Standard 0W, Keckel,
Rom, Iteration, Start, End, Uint, 69, Rom, so das ist ungefähr ziemlich, ziemlich, ziemlich
valid C++, ungefähr so sieht das aus, du brauchst noch ein paar Operator, Overloaded, plus gleich,
Void, Void, Int, Int, Call, Make, Shared und davon dann die Adresse, also Leute ohne Scheiß
wahrscheinlich ist das valid C++ Code und wer jetzt sagt ist nicht so, ich könnte fast
wetten, dass es lauffähig machbar ist in C++, also das könnte durchaus valid, okay mit
dem Pointer, mit der Adresse hier vorne funktionieren, das könnte wahrscheinlich wirklich fast valid
C++ sein, das ist halt echt abartig.
Könnt ihr gut mit Entwurfsmustern, ich kenne niemand, ich kenne niemand der Entwurfsmuster
sagt, aber die meisten davon brauchst du nicht, viele sind in aktmodernen Sprachen
schon integriert, sowas wie Observer zum Beispiel und wenn du in Java unterwegs bist, dann brauchst
du natürlich das Abstract Factory Repository Manager Builder Pattern, sonst gehts nicht,
ich glaube zwei davon sind gar keine offiziellen Entwurfsmuster aus diesem Buch, wie heißt
dieses Gang of Five, ne wie heißt dieses Oldschool Entwurfsmuster Buch, Gang of Four, aber vieles
davon ist in modernen Sprachen schon eingebaut, also ganz ehrlich das wichtigste Pattern ist
meiner Meinung nach Observer und Factory, wobei Factory je nach Sprache auch schon einen
gewissen Weg hat wie man es macht, okay warte mal, ne nicht Design Pattern, nach was muss
ich suchen, Gang of Four Design Patterns, also in.NET voll angesagt, braucht man relativ
oft, braucht man auch relativ oft, in vielen Sprachen auch schon eingebaut, semi oft, jede
moderne Sprache hat sowas, auch mit Interfaces meistens, als Libraries, Observer auch oft
schon eingebaut in modernen Sprachen, ja, alles bloated, Yandere Dankeschön für den
Besuch, ich wünsche euch einen schönen Abend, bis zum nächsten Mal, tschüss, tschüss,
tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss,
Javascript ist weird, weird champ, okay zeig mal her, also wir wissen, dass Javascript weird
ist.
Also in Javascript ist not a number auch nicht not a number, das ist ja klar ne, also hier
none, gleich, gleich, was kommt da raus chat, was kommt da raus, wenn ich jetzt n eingebe?
Da kommt false raus, sieht man ja, not a number equals not a number ist logischerweise false,
obviously und jetzt kommt der Trick, was kommt hier raus, Mist node schreibt immer unten
drunter was, da weiß man es ja schon und was kommt hier raus, das gibt es nicht, okay.
Ja, das ist ja Batman, Batman, was, ne, ah ich hab's nicht in der Historie, das gibt
es ja auch, da gibt es ja auch die Batman Variante.
Moment, 21, ich guck mir jetzt noch nicht 21 Minuten an, warum Javascript weird champ
ist, das wissen wir doch auch so.
Also das glaube ich dem sofort, das glaube ich dem sofort, ich mein das Klammern funktionieren
an der Stelle, versteh ich, das ist einfach quasi Statement kopiert, geschweifte Klammer
auf ist ein Objekt, eckige Klammer auf ist ein Array, aber warum dieser Shit da innen
drinne funktioniert ist mir nicht ganz klar, geteilt durch größer plus not kleiner gleich,
ich habe keine Ahnung warum das funktioniert.
Also das ist genau das, was wir hier machen werden, also das ist einfach, Javascript
only has a few basic types, like strings, numbers, booleans, arrays and objects, ja und
wenn ich es richtig in Erinnerung hab, sind Numbers in Javascript 47 bit, ich glaube Numbers
in Javascript sind 47 bit, oder 42 bit, warum, weil die schlau sein wollten, die verwenden
47 bit für die eigentliche Zahl und, was ist denn da noch übrig, 17, 17 Stellen für
den Exponent, Pfeifedder Time, es könnten auch 52 bit sein, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
aber das habe ich auch mal, hier, Javascript numbers also 0 bis genau 52 bits ist der value,
genau und der Rest ist für den Exponent, das ist, ja in Javascript gibt es das ja nicht,
in Javascript gibt es nur Numbers, das wird mich nicht wundern, dass Javascript irgendwelche
Standards ignoriert, achja Chat, mal Frage, was kommt hier raus, wer weiß es, was kommt
hier raus in Javascript, wenn man das, wenn ich das so checken lasse in Javascript, und
was kommt hier raus, node, true, gleich, gleich, jetzt kommts, jetzt kommts, true, logischerweise
false, das ist auch false, ist insofern ja auch logisch, weil es ist ja auch kein String,
ja.
Ah, obviously, natürlich, was sonst Javascript, also 2, 2 plus true, also 2 plus true, also
das heißt im Endeffekt, ich kann, true plus true Rechner kommt 2 raus, na klar, was sonst,
pass mal auf, pass mal auf, 5 hat, 5 hat time, node, true plus false, gleich true, so was
geht aber auch echt nur in Javascript oder, aber das ist false, das ist false, ja, bitte
schön, gibt es inzwischen type safety, naja es gibt jetzt glaube ich seit dem neuesten
Standard type annotations, gleich, gleich, gleich ist, dass er nicht, dass er überprüft,
ob der Typ stimmt auch oder so, frag mich nicht genau, Javascript Details aus dem Kopf.
Aber selbst wenn wir supplies versionieren, so welches wir hier in den
D plus A and then plus and then a space plus and then A plus A and then we do a two lowercase on that we should see this come out with the string banana.
Warum muss man to lowercase machen?
What we're trying to do here, the root of it, is that we're trying to take the character A and convert it into a number with a unary plus, which of course is going to result in not a number because A is not a number and cannot be sensibly transformed into a number.
And if you two lowercase that, you'll get the middle part of the string.
And if we look at what it was before, you'll see that this is really this.
So what we're actually doing is saying B plus A plus not a number plus A lowercase.
It's actually fairly simple.
This is the set of basic things that we're gonna use in order to do something way cooler.
So first of all, let's figure out how we can get numbers.
Ja, würde ich auch jedem empfehlen, lernt JavaScript ein bisschen, bevor ihr euch noch TypeScript obendrauf packt.
Ich verwende ja bis heute kaum TypeScript.
TypeScript hat auch so seine Abfachseiten. Ich habe letztens gesehen irgendeiner, der rein im TypeScript-Typesystem irgendeinen Encoder programmiert hat.
Nur mit dem TypeScript-Typesystem.
Ich glaube, ein Base64-Encoder rein im TypeScript-Typesystem oder irgendwas habe ich letztens auf Twitter gesehen, habe ich auch schon gedacht.
Jetzt fängt es schon an wie ein C++.
Was wir eigentlich tun müssen, ist es irgendwie von unserem Haupttypen zu bekommen.
Welche Sprache ist nicht Trash? Ganz ehrlich, ich würde sagen JavaScript ist nicht Trash, unabhängig davon. JavaScript ist mittlerweile echt ganz gut, brauchbar. C Sharp ist definitiv auch nicht Trash.
Für so normale Daily-Anwendungen eigentlich nicht wirklich geeignet.
Großer Go-Fan werde ich nicht werden, aber ich würde nicht so weit gehen und sagen, dass es Trash ist. Ruby ist auch auf jeden Fall kein Trash.
Python ist auch kein Trash.
Bash ist auch kein Trash. Bash ist einfach nur alt.
Kotlin ist auch kein Trash.
Cobol ist Trash, ja, da gebe ich dir recht. C++ ist auch Trash.
C ist kein Trash.
Bash ist aber keine Sprache.
Na ja, kann man es jetzt drüber schreiben? Ich meine, du kannst da auch das meiste drin machen. Du hast Ifs, du hast Schleifen, du hast Funktionsaufrufe, also im Prinzip...
Also, für mich geht das als Programmiersprache durch.
Aber ich bin da eh nicht so pingelig.
Wer ist... Ja, da kommt... Das ist Test, ist das.
Die eckige Klammer.
Lua ist Trashwing ArrayIndex1. Ja, das stimmt. Es ist auf jeden Fall ein wenig Sass, wie man so schön sagt.
Welche Sprachen sind so richtig Trash, aber nicht, weil sie so alt wie Cobol sind?
C++?
Denn die neuesten C++-Standards haben es nicht wirklich viel weniger trashig gemacht.
Ähm...
Tja.
Ja, Brainfuck ist ja dafür gemacht, fuck zu sein, ja.
Portran ist auch alt. Tja, welche Sprache ist neu und trash?
Also, so wirklich trash, so. Das ist doch nicht mal...
Ganz ehrlich, ob Carbon was taugt, bin ich mir wirklich sehr unschlüssig.
Ob das irgendwie eine Daseinsberechtigung hat.
Was ich von Dart gesehen hab, bisher war wirklich nicht so geil.
Aber kommst ja mit Flutter nicht drumherum.
TempleOS ist keine Programmiersprache.
TempleOS ist in Holy C programmiert.
PAP ist auch kein Trash.
Moderne PAP-Versionen sind echt ganz okay.
Okay.
Emacs Lisp ist Trash.
Das ist nicht so alt wie Cobol und ist trotzdem Trash.
Scala kann ich auch nicht ab.
Also alle Sprachen, die zu 90% aus Klammern bestehen, im Prinzip so was wie Emacs Lisp oder Scala,
ist Pains Jam. Erlang ist auch so ein Ding.
Egal, wir gucken jetzt weiter.
Obviosly.
Scala mit Acker.
Ist Acker nicht so ein Clustering verteiltes Zeug-Framework?
Ich hab da irgendwas im Hinterkopf in die Richtung, bin ich mir aber nicht ganz sicher.
Er ist Trash? Weiß ich nicht, Chat. Hab ich noch nichts mitgemacht?
Prolog? Da kenn ich nur irgendwelche Hallo-Welt-Beispiele.
ABAP, naja. Ist ABAP das SAP-Ding?
Das Video, da schlaf ich ein bei, Leute. Da passiert ja nichts.
Außer, dass er uns zeigt, dass du mit JavaScript-Webchamp Zeug machen kannst.
ABAP ist SAP, ja.
Was verdient ein Berufsjäger?
Das gucken wir uns mal hier früh an.
Der Jägersmann.
Pre-Pre-Pre-Alpha-Battlefield-Gameplay.
Was für ein Battlefield könnte das sein?
Ist das Bad Company?
Ist das die Bad Company Alpha?
Das ist Bad Company, oder?
Jaja, das ist Bad Company.
Also ich vermute mal, das wird Bad Company.
Jaja, das wird garantiert Bad Company.
Mods, einmal Bunn, please.
Jaja, das hörst du auch an der Hintergrundmusik. Das ist Bad Company 2.
Bad Company 1, nicht Bad Company 2, Bad Company 1.
Was ist das?
I tried 10 code editors. Wer braucht code editors? See it only.
Die Auswahl ist aber auch reichlich willkürlich, oder?
Was ist denn das alles?
Ist eins davon NeoWim? Keine Ahnung.
Das da oben sagt mir gar nichts.
Was ist das da unten? Was ist das unten rechts?
Ach, das ist Fleet, genau.
Nee, ich glaube nicht, dass es Dreamweaver ist, oder?
Dreamweaver, das habe ich früher verwendet. 1999 für Webseiten.
Seht, seht only.
Nee, ich habe damals kein Frontpage verwendet. Ich habe tatsächlich schon HTML selbst gemacht.
Also Dreamweaver konnte ja HTML Editor und, ähm, ja, Visivic Editor.
Aber das Autokomplete von Dreamweaver war wirklich seinerzeit voraus. Also das konnte mehr oder weniger alles Autokompleten schon.
Wobei es ja eigentlich Wim ist im Kompatibilitätsmodus.
Ja, Wim Beste.
Ich benutze Wim täglich halt für kleine Editiersachen, SSH, Commandline, sonst wie.
Deswegen habe ich meine ganze Wim-Config auch wieder eingekürzt von dem riesen Ding, was ich früher hatte.
Einfach weil es überall funktioniert. Wim ist das Beste.
Nee, du brauchst kein Studium für Wim. Du musst es einfach nur ein paar Wochen mal verwenden regelmäßig für kleine Terminal-Editiersachen, dann gewöhnst du dich dran.
Wim hat, die Wim-Sprache hat eine gewisse Logik.
Ja, das habe ich ja schon öfters gesagt. Also zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt hier irgendwie sowas stehen hast, oder sagen wir mal was anderes. Sagen wir mal, du hast jetzt hier irgendwie sowas hier stehen. Lul, W, bla bla bla.
Und du willst jetzt alles in den, alles in den Anführungszeichen löschen. Dann sagst du einfach C, I, Anführungszeichen.
Hä, seit wann muss man da drin sein? Ach nee, man muss davor sein. Jaja, man muss davor sein. Du sagst, du sagst C, I, Anführungszeichen, dann springt er da rein und löscht das. Das kann man sich merken. C für Change, I für Inner und dann das Zeichen von wo bis wo.
Also das hat, also die Wim-Sprache hat schon seinen Sinn. Also das hat eine gewisse Konsistenz, was die einzelnen Kürzel machen.
Ja, das macht aber keiner.
Please allow me to interject for a moment. Weiß nicht, ob wir das Zeug ready haben im Chat.
Genau das.
Ja, das Problem ist, dass es Emacs Lisp hat zum Konfigurieren und Emacs Lisp ist wirklich auch ziemlich belastend.
Ich kenne niemand, der in Emacs die Menüs verwendet.
Ja, es interessiert aber keinen mehr. Ganz ehrlich, Emacs hat seit Whistle Studio Code und der Erweiterbarkeit dort mit Plugins schon noch weiter an Bedeutung verloren.
Das war ja halt das Coole an Emacs, dass du so viele Plugins hattest und quasi eine eingebaute Sprache zum Plugins entwickeln, aber ganz ehrlich, ich glaube Emacs, die Bedeutung ist mittlerweile nicht mehr groß vorhanden.
Aber auch nur weil Emacs verwendet.
Ich kenne keinen mehr, der Emacs benutzt. Ich kenne welche, die haben Emacs, aber ich kenne keinen, der wirklich noch Emacs dauerhaft benutzt.
Es ist cool, dass es so viele Wim-Plugins gibt, aber ganz im Ernst, ich bin da weg von, ich hatte ja mein Wim früher aufgebohrt, ich hatte irgendwie, was weiß ich, 2000 Zeilen WimRC oder sonst was.
Ich konnte das Ding nicht mehr abdecken, ohne dass es kaputt gegangen ist und du hast es halt auf Remote Server nicht. Es gibt da ein paar Tricks, das mitzunehmen, aber da kopierst du erst mal.
Ich hatte sogar ein Sync-Programm, was mir per SSH meine Wim-Config mit kopiert hat, wo es dann das Problem war, da musste ich erst mal 40 MB sinken oder was komplett useless war, das kannst du vergessen, kannst du nicht verwenden.
Deswegen bin ich mittlerweile wieder auf Vanilla Wim ohne Plugins. Ich glaube das einzige Plugin, was ich habe, ist eine ordentliche Statusleiste.
Ja, das ist eh overrated. Das ist total overrated in der heutigen Zeit. Du verbringst eh die meiste Zeit beim Programmieren mit nachdenken, mit googeln und mit Sachen lesen und den Browser benutzen.
Das ist egal. Du brauchst die zweite Hand eh öfters für die Maus. Insofern, das ist nur ein theoretischer Vorteil.
Also man erkennt Leute, die noch nie was entwickelt haben und nie was programmiert haben, daran, dass sie denken, Programmierer machen den ganzen Tag das hier. Ist es halt nicht.
Das Problem ist, dass Wim-Skript...
Oh, ja. Deswegen haben sie jetzt Lua in Neo Wim eingebaut. Genau, wie er sagt.
Nein, Tastaturlayouts habe ich mich noch nicht dazu irgendwie durchgerungen. Ich sehe auch ganz ehrlich den Vorteil nicht, sich da jetzt monatelang rumzuquälen und umzugewöhnen.
Also den Boost in der Produktivität sehe ich da nicht.
Nanomagisch nicht. Nanomagisch nicht. Nano ist quasi Notepad nur im Terminal und das funktioniert nicht.
Ja gut, Notepad ist im Prinzip ja heute noch mehr oder weniger das gleiche wie das da. Da hat sich ja so gut wie nix dran getan.
Kennt noch jemand? Kennt noch jemand?
Kennt noch jemand? Kennt noch jemand Edit? Nee, wie ist das Ding? Ultra Edit? Kennt noch jemand Ultra Edit?
Das war so 2000 rum. Der Shit für Windows an Editor. Verwendet heute kein Mensch mehr, aber das war damals voll Bleeding Edge.
Moment, man kann sich den Kram heute noch kaufen oder was? High Performance Winner. Gut, da haben sie sich mal wieder selbst irgendwelche...
The Bugatti of Text Editors. Alter, was ein Blödsinn, Mann. Moment, mit Subscription? Die haben doch einen Dachschaden.
Subscription für einen Text Editor. Oh, Dreamweaver. Dreamweaver kenn ich nur, das war ein grünes... Moment, hat das nicht eben gezeigt?
Das grüne Logo kenn ich noch. Ja, da ist Dreamweaver. Dreamweaver 7. Das da, oder war das schon 8? Ja. Das hab ich damals verwendet, um Webseiten zu machen.
Das gibt es noch? Das gibt es wirklich noch? Auch mit Dark Theme und so? Was ist die Daseinsberechtigung 2022?
JQuery UI. Ja.
Rackets wird auch glaub ich noch mal weiterentwickelt. Ja. Das ist das Ding, kechthin aktuell. Zumindest für Frontend Sachen.
Ja. Was der Grund ist, warum auch Emacs nicht mehr so angesagt ist. Diese Sache mit Erweiterung und Plugins war ja das riesen Ding von Emacs früher.
Mittlerweile hast du halt dann auch mal ne gescheite Sprache. Keiner mag und kann E-Lisp wirklich. JavaScript können die meisten.
Ja, musst du ja auch. Musst du ja auch. Du brauchst ja nen Mac, um Mac Anwendungen beziehungsweise iOS Anwendungen machen zu können.
Weil du brauchst ja diesen komischen Code Signing Schritt von Apple, was nur mit Mac OS geht.
Oder einfach Rider verwenden, was besser ist und kostet Plattform.
Rider hat keine gratis Version. Nee, du hast nur ne Trial Version.
Ist doch wurscht. Ganz ehrlich, wenn man damit sein Geld verdient sind 69 Euro im Jahr kein Ding. Ich hab das All Desktop Package, das kostet mich 160 Euro pro Jahr.
Ich mag aber das Standard Farbschema nicht. Nee, IntelliJ ist nicht das einzige gratis Ding. PyCharm ist auch gratis. Sonst noch was gratis?
Nee, Golan ist glaub ich auch nur mit Sub.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Die Zukunft sieht interessant aus, aber der wichtigste Take-Away von diesem Video ist...
...dass es keine Drogen gibt.
Danke fürs Zuschauen und wir sehen uns in der nächsten!
Ja, jetzt ist der Stream doch länger gegangen, für das, dass ich nach 15 Minuten eigentlich schon aufgehen wollte.
Ja, ich bin da auch kein großer Fan von irgendwelche Cloud-IDEs zu verwenden.
Ich mein, vielleicht für Leute, die irgendwie total viel unterwegs sind und dann vom Notebook aus irgendwo was machen wollen und so.
Vielleicht, aber ansonsten...
Tja...
Okay, Leute, es reicht!
Lange genug halb eingepennt vorm Rechner.
Ich mach jetzt den Stream aus, guck noch ein paar Videos und dann geh ich irgendwann in so eineinhalb Stunden pennen oder so.
Alles klar, wir sehen uns, macht's gut, see you!